[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today is an associate professor of law
at Georgetown Law School as well as the
founder of prison professors dot-com
Sean Hopwood welcome to the Rubin report
all right thanks for having me so I
gotta tell you man I have been in
partnership with learn Liberty for about
a year and a half or so and it's a great
partnership they send me a list of great
professors and academics from all over
the country they say if you want to talk
to any of these people
we'll make them available easy enough
you have by far the craziest bio of
anyone that they have passed along to me
I suspect you know that in advance you
don't have many public intellectuals who
have gone to federal prison for robbing
banks you are the first one out of the
law I mean they've given us lists of
hundreds of people that we select out of
I I've gotten used to be in the Freak
Show yeah one point it used to bother me
but I I tend to embrace it now yeah so
yes you spent 12 years in a federal
prison for bank robbery we're obviously
gonna have to hear that story should I
be concerned at all that this is in my
house you've now seen my security system
and everything else I think you'll be
okay yeah when I took a meeting while
you were sitting in the green room I
thought maybe he could be you know doing
some stuff but yeah yeah probably
emailing with students yeah all right
that's my new life these days
that's your new life you have cleaned up
you're wearing a suit you've got legit
as they say I've cleaned up I brought my
First Amendment socks with me yeah yeah
Oh
given the finger to the man that's right
all right a big believer on the First
Amendment I'm pretty much a First
Amendment absolutist me too all right
well then we're in good company here all
right so here we go so let's just start
with it with the big story you've robbed
a bank what are you doing yeah robbed
five of them what was I doing I was a
young 20 year old man who had no purpose
in life and did not weigh out the
consequences of my actions on myself so
it's not hard to realize that I wasn't
really thinking about the consequences
of my actions on anyone else and
everyone always wants to what was the
big reason why and the reason is I was
young and 20 and stupid
and part of my Redemption out of that
was just growing up alright so just tell
me how this even happens when does the
idea of I'll rob a bank like you can be
young and yes and missguided and
everything else and do you you might you
know steal some stuff from the candy
store
robbing a bank differently ya know that
that's right a friend of mine invited me
to the bar in my hometown sprawling
metropolis of 2,500 people and rural
Nebraska and said hey what do you think
about robbing a bank and most people
would have said no you're crazy laughs
done anything and my response was that
sounds like a great idea and so we
discussed it over beers and I don't
think either one of us thought we were
gonna actually do it yeah that night but
we started taking steps and then once we
got into it it was kind of took me on a
downward spiral yeah so from that
conversation to to the first robbery how
long was that probably six months okay
so now just had that we had to hide
ourselves up to actually do it yeah so
what were those conversations like I
mean what were their multiple plans of
how to go about doing this was this all
like the way you see it in old Western
just showing up at the No yeah give me
some yeah we planned it out we had
stolen a car went to the bank ran in the
bank with guns yelled at everyone
grabbed as much money as we could we
never intended to hurt anyone
the guns were there pretty much for show
and then we left and dumped the stolen
car and got into a grain truck because
this was August in Nebraska and no one's
gonna think about bank robbers being in
a grain truck and we drove life and you
did this five times yeah you know once
we started doing it I had to use drugs
and alcohol to kind of get over the fact
that I had a lot of guilt it's not like
I didn't know this was wrong yeah and so
once we got into it we started spending
money when you make using money it's
easy to spend it yeah just was a year of
trying to party that
fascinating so you get all this money
and now the guilt of the action is now
the financial part that's fueling yeah
sure you're need to do it again yeah I
was going through depression and some
other issues and I just I needed I
needed somebody to say what are you
doing
and I never really got that and the guys
I were with we're all in the same place
early 20s didn't have a job didn't know
what they wanted to do with their life
and we kind of filled each other for
this year-long spree yeah putting aside
the the drugs for a second I mean what
about the rush of just doing it I would
imagine you know even though it it's a
criminal act obviously but just like
getting away with something that sounds
so crazy yeah no it's not really a rush
every time you go in the bank everything
in your body is you do not do this you
kind of have to shut that off yeah you
kind of have to shut rational thought
down because if it was rational you
would not be doing it if you were
thinking rationally you would not walk
into a bank because you know at the end
of the day I got less than $200,000 for
all those banks well served 11 years in
prison and ended up having to pay all
the money back anyway and so rationally
didn't make much sense from a
cost-benefit analysis maybe isn't the
best idea well this is this is why this
is one of the big reasons why we impose
long sentences on people in this country
is this belief in general deterrence if
I give you a 20-year sentence it's gonna
deter everyone else all the literature
says that that doesn't actually happen
yeah people that commit crimes are a lot
of it is young men 18 to 25 these are
not people that weigh out the
consequences mm-hmm
drug addiction alcoholism mental health
issues again not people that weigh out
the consequences of their actions but
even if they did let's just pretend they
did mm-hmm
what would they have to do to find out
how long they would be sentenced for a
particular they would have to find one
of 5,000 federal statutes right that
sets the mandatory minimum and maximum
penalties then they'd have to read a 500
page guideline manual that judges and
lawyers miss apply every day to think
anyone's actually doing that is
ludicrous yeah I never met one person 11
years in prison who knew how much time
they were facing but this is the primary
argument that people like the Attorney
General and other the tough-on-crime
crowd believes we should pose long
sentences because it will deter everyone
else yeah so this is what you've really
devoted your life to since and I want to
get to all that obviously and we just
briefly spoke about the Attorney General
I want to talk about him because I'm
frustrated about some stuff as well okay
so how much time cook place for those
five bank robberies like what kind of
time frame are we looking at less than a
year less than a year so within a year
okay now you get caught you end up in a
federal prison for I thought it was 12
you said 11 but maybe there's three
months without a sentence but I got good
time for behaving in prison okay so I
served less than 11 years okay so less
than the 11 years just tell me what that
process even just tell me first what
that first day of showing up at a
federal prison
is like it's not what you would think
it's not orange is the new black it's
not orange is the new black the first
day in prison and the first week in
prison felt like freedom and the reason
I say that is I was moved around like
many people that are pretrial from
County Jail to County Jail where you're
locked down maybe 20 hours out of the
day and when I got to prison I could
actually go outside I hadn't been
outside in them Oh nine months well when
I got to prison I could go outside I
could go to the library I could pick out
books I could do something to occupy my
mind
and so the first couple weeks in prison
outside of the part of being scared to
death felt like more freedom huh what
was the scary part beyond just being a
guard I mean like just all the physical
threats here like physical threats
threats of sexual assault you know I
watched a lot of people with medical
issues die in federal prison because
they weren't adequately treated and you
know then the real punishment is you
don't you're cut off from all your
family and community ties which is a
problem because we know that people that
are able to maintain community and
family ties is key for people coming out
of prison especially if you come out of
prison you get a job and you lose the
job or get fired
if you don't have family or some sort of
community to fall back on that's usually
when people go back to committing crime
right and that's part of the reason of
high rates of recidivism yeah in all of
this stuff
yeah the rates of recidivism in this
country are not good they range from 45%
to 75% we have some state prison systems
that within five years everyone leaving
the prison 75% of them will come back I
mean that's just mind-blowing like
putting everything else aside that we're
going to talk about for the next hour if
just the idea that you put people here
to punish them for this crime and then
more than half in many cases and you're
saying sometimes significantly more and
up back there man
I mean what it what a failure what a
true failure what what I mean government
programs that fail three out of four
times and no one really it is disturbing
yeah you know anyone who has an out date
and is gonna come out of prison we
should be trying to rehabilitate those
people for a number of reasons one
public safety do not want people coming
out of prison and committing new crimes
new victims it costs a lot of money to
reprosecution ajudge the public defender
and then their incarceration so you got
that issue but you also have an issue
with we want people to come back and
lead law by in successful lives and if
you've just warehouse somebody for 10
years and then you kick them out to the
streets with no or little support and no
family or community ties and then you
expect a miracle to happen and then when
it doesn't we say oh you were evil
because we you were gonna fail and go
back to prison commit a new crime anyway
yeah now you were truly the aberration
in the system because you have a little
bit of a Shawshank
kind of story here because Andy Dufresne
took things into his own hands one in a
couple different ways legally and by
digging the tunnel but you started
getting into law this is fascinating to
me yeah I got a job at the president law
library and for the first couple months
all I did was hand out the books they
were big they were thick they were
intimidating when I did pull one down
off the shelves and read it felt like it
was written in another language right
who
was reading the books I mean was
everyone there trying to solve their
case without there were people there was
there were a lot but there were people
trying to fight their case especially in
federal prison when when a lot of people
were getting 20 30 year mandatory
minimums for a handful of crack cocaine
mm-hmm so people are trying to fight
their cases and I didn't want anything
to do with that until June 26th of 2000
the Supreme Court handed down a decision
called aprende V New Jersey I like
everyone else in federal prison thought
that this might apply to the federal
sentencing guidelines so I started
learning the law on my own and was never
able to get any relief for myself but
what I found was I enjoyed solving this
legal puzzle and kind of writing out the
solution so I started helping other
people in prison keep going then what
happened this is where it gets good that
that is up to your to your career now
and your whole life yeah I started
writing memos for people friends of mine
their lawyers saying hey check out these
issues and here's some case law the
lawyers often time would be like yeah
whatever I mean do people think you were
now yeah what about their prisoners
think like well I mean they don't know
good legal work from bad right so many
of them had bad lawyers to begin with
and they were desperate so they would
help me and I finally started to write a
briefer to and we would file
post-conviction motions and the third
legal brief I ever prepared was for a
friend of mine named John fellers who
was filing what's called a petition for
writ of certiorari to the United States
Supreme Court I didn't know a great deal
about the Supreme Court but I knew it
was different than filing in other
courts that court gets 8,000 petitions
7,000 petitions a year they grant 70 to
80 cases you've got a 1% chance that the
1% is for lawyers filing rates to the
court when you are filing pro se as an
indigent prisoner with no lawyer and
you're the prisoners name is on the
front cover yeah a chance of getting one
of those heard is about 1% of 1% Wow and
so do you know how many times that was
done before you
I think it's been done 20 times Wow 25
times
since the 1950s not a lot yeah so you
know I didn't think a great deal about
John's case I thought we were right on
the issues and I thought the issues were
important
John transferred to another prison and I
forgot about his case until one morning
at 6:30 in the morning a friend of mine
came running and screaming out of the
housing unit Sean Sean you know let's be
in federal prison I thought what did I
say to him yesterday it wants to come
fight me at 6:30 in the morning yeah
usually when people are running and
screaming at each other not good doesn't
it's not good but you don't normally go
to a fight carrying a newspaper in your
hand and what he had was a copy of the
USA USA Today saying that the court had
granted John fellers case how unlikely
that was given John had filed without a
lawyer and it actually quoted from the
brief that I had pecked out on a prison
typewriter I knew that was a big deal
did I know that it would lead to doing
this work long term no that I know it
was I was going to go to law school or
become a lawyer no and I certainly never
thought I would end up as a law
professor at Georgetown yeah so what
happened right after that I mean did the
prison administrators go man this guy's
yeah well the big break for John fellers
and and myself was that an attorney took
the case over and not just any attorney
has named Seth Waxman he's the former
Solicitor General of the United States
and one of the top appellate lawyers in
the country he took the case and I think
most people and with his background
Harvard undergrad Yale Law School
clerked for federal judges worked at the
Department of Justice was the Solicitor
General would have said hey good job
mass mr. Dale House lawyer without a
bachelor's degree great work we'll take
it from here and yet he did the exact
opposite they would send in he and his
firm Wilmer Hale would send in drafts of
the brief I would markup it with notes
and I would send it back out one point I
know one point I had a conference call
in my counselor's office was sattim
three other lawyers the week before oral
arguments and Seth asked me Sean can you
think of any questions that the justices
might ask the
we haven't thought about and I'm sitting
there thinking I'm like I have been
self-learning the law for 18 months I've
never even taken freshman English ya
know I have no idea what the courts
gonna ask you and they started laughing
but it was quite the experience what do
you make of I mean it's a fascinating
that Waxman was willing to do this do
you think it was truly he was trying to
get your insight as a prisoner I mean
obviously he saw a good legal mind even
if it was a novice at the time do you
think it was also like just like a PR
element to that as well like I'm gonna
stick with this guy and there's some
value there too I think he was curious I
think he was curious that he had looked
at this petition that was typed on a
prison typewriter and had been granted
and he thought it was a really good work
product and he was surprised when he
discovered that it had been prepared by
a federal prisoner with no background in
the law whatsoever who had just kind of
been picking this up on his own yeah and
and I think he thought that there was
value there and and you know he became a
mentor to me we won the case 9 to 0 and
he has been a good friend he introduced
me a couple months ago at the DC bar
galas I want young lawyer of the Year
award and Seth walked up there and
introduced me to the crowd and we were
just sitting there at the table thinking
things have come full circle for us yeah
it's so funny because you're a young guy
the idea of like typing this thing up on
a typewriter you just that alone do they
white out and cut no they don't yeah you
think you could trade that because I
feel like there's some value to this
probably things you can do it right out
oh yeah yeah yeah I typed up a lot of
things on a present typewriter almost
all the briefs I prepare I never was
allowed to touch a computer while I was
incarcerated so when I get out in 2008
I had never been on the Internet
incredible never seen an iPhone and iPad
and iPod one of the things that I
struggled was finding the jobs 2008 it
was the height of the recession no one
was finding work let alone the bank
robber that just did 11 years in federal
prison yeah tell me about that day when
you when they officially say to you okay
you get
and then what is it like when you're
actually putting are you literally
putting on the clothes that you walked
in with it they said no that's sort of
the image that yeah right
somebody had sent me clothes my brother
picked me up to take me to the halfway
house I still had six months of custody
with the be ope but I was going to serve
it at the halfway house across the river
from Nebraska in Council Bluffs Iowa and
my brother picks me up and we drive and
we go to a Walmart and I needed to pick
up toothpaste
and I remember just being stuck in the
Walmart in an aisle because there was a
wall of toothpaste and I had not had
choice mm-hmm for over a decade and it
was overwhelming and I'm not one that
stresses or gets a great deal of anxiety
but I tell you my first 30 days at the
halfway house I was consuming four to
five thousand calories a day and losing
weight well just because of the anxiety
of trying to figure out this new world
yeah you know one of the places that my
big break was getting a job with kaká
legal briefs this company in Omaha that
helps lawyers all over the country file
briefs to the US Supreme Court they had
asked me I told them I had this
reference letter from Seth Waxman that
really impressed them I didn't tell them
the rest of the story yeah don't ask
where I was really they said send us a
PDF I didn't know what a PDF was no one
else in the halfway house did either so
when I walk into the interview I have to
pull this reference letter out of my
pocket and hand it to them yeah and you
know if that if that cost me that job
I'm not sitting here today so tell me
about that so now you so now you're oh
you know what let's just do a little
more on prison itself and then we'll
move into everything that you're working
on now I think when we think of prison
you know so much of it is just what we
see in TV and movies you know I watched
eyes years ago i watch orange is the new
black now like we think of like just so
much crime actually in prison which
sounds like it should be the reverse of
the way it is but yet there is how much
of that did you see in the federal
system
I saw more federal drug arm or I saw
more drugs in federal prison than I ever
saw outside as someone that was doing
drugs before
yeah it's not and there were several
guards that were federally indicted
during my time in prison it's kind of
ironic to me that you have a prison with
two fences with razor wire around it and
really high security and we can't keep
the drugs out of federal prison how are
we ever gonna do that for an entire
country yeah
sy the war on drugs will never be
successful was there a real difference
in the type of prisoner that was there
for you know obviously there's some well
is a bank robber he's not considered a
white that's not a white collar right no
it's a violent crime right of course so
but wait is there a difference between
okay so you have someone that's you know
murderers and rapists and you know then
there's the sort of a lesser violent
crime something like a bank robber
versus just the people that did drugs
either either sold but I'm really
talking with the people who just did
drugs was there a real sort of
separation between those two types of
people know what I saw in prison was
there was a small sliver of people who
were dangerous and who would be very
difficult to reform without a lot of
behavioral changes yeah but it's a very
small sliver most of the people I saw
especially people for drug crimes most
of them were doing drugs and selling
drugs to support their habit and they
just needed a year or two of being clean
mm-hmm problem was they would get clean
after two years and realized oh I've got
18 more years to do in federal prison I
also just saw a lot of guys that you
know we're just regular guys that that
made bad choices and had amazing talents
and had the capacity to get out and lead
law-abiding successful lives but they
needed a little support and they needed
some incentives to take rehabilitation
programming and there wasn't a lot of
programming at the prison yeah all right
now let's let's shift that so you so you
leave prison you get your first legit
gig so what actually was your job your
first job yeah so I consulted with
lawyers every day on the phone about
filing their briefs in the US Supreme
Court and you know that first year was
difficult for the people that worked at
cockell it was
difficult for my wife I went from an
environment with nothing but guys that
were in federal prison for 11 years to
an office of almost all women and and
was with my wife and I talked like a
prisoner acted like a president and they
had to really sand off some rough edges
than that first year yeah with that like
I mean it's just a lot of [ __ ] no I
mean I mean so I would get frustrated
when a lawyer would call me up and say
hey I've got this petition due in two
days and I would said well good send it
here will help get you filed well I
haven't written it yet and you know
they're representing someone who's got a
30-year mandatory minimum that would
make me mad and and at one time I got
called into the office manager and she
said Sean you know our whole job here is
customer service so you can't really
tell lawyers to get their [ __ ] yeah
that's fine just little things like that
that you know I I had been in a
different environment and it took me a
while to adapt yeah well I think clearly
that adaptation is what has led to some
of your success how much did you see
sort of lawyers that were just part of
the machine that kind of weren't doing
anything wasting a lot of times they
could build people where for you it was
like I found this information yeah
now I want to like help as many people
as possible and get things to happen in
a timely manner itself I see lots of
lawyers who their clients are a source
of revenue for them you know that's that
happens every day and in every field not
just criminal law sure but I also see a
lot of lawyers who are very passionate
and advocates for their clients who do a
lot of things for their clients that
they're not getting paid for and you
know those those lawyers I admire
because you know it's not easy to
represent criminal defendants and the
American criminal justice system yeah so
when did you get into teaching when did
you decide to make that route well first
I went to law school and then after that
I decided that my first job I'd like to
clerk for a federal judge and had a lot
of people tell me that may not be able
to happen for you Sean you've done well
in law school but there may be some
people that
will not think that you should be
clerking and I also got some advice from
people when I was in law school about if
you do apply for a federal clerkship
only apply to Democrat appointees
Republican appointees will not give you
the time of day given your background
interesting and yet almost every judge
that interviewed me or was interested in
me was a Republican appointee and and
ultimately it was judge Janice Rogers
Brown who was one of the most
conservative judges on the DC Circuit
she's no longer a judge now it was her
that hired me former bank robber to come
be her clerk at the second most
important court in the country yeah so I
want to obviously get into your time
there but what do you make of that that
statement that you just said that people
said well it'll probably be a Democrat
but it turned out to be a Republican
well I think I think people don't
realize that I think of for a lot of
conservatives they really redemption
stories resonate with them whether it's
the faith aspect or just you know they
probably view me as a pick yourself up
by the bootstraps story which that's not
entirely accurate because if I don't
have people like Seth wax one of my wife
none of this happens but I think that
resonated with them and and they you
know I had lots of judges who wanted to
give me an opportunity yeah and now
basically you are helping a lot of young
people get that opportunity yeah yes rec
hall chambers of federal judges all the
time to try and get my students
clerkships yeah and so you know I spent
a year clerking and I got to see kind of
how the sausage is made
appellate court and what was the most
mind-blowing part of that were there
things that you saw that you were like
wow this is really messed up and it this
will probably lead us to a lot of the
issues that you're fighting about all
the time well I was surprised sometimes
at level of advocacy even on a court in
Washington DC that's viewed as the
second most important court in the
country
a lot of times the advocacy was really
bad especially in criminal cases
you mean the public defenders public
defenders Bheema privately retain
lawyers at least public defenders care
and so they won't just check it in but I
saw privately retain lawyers that would
file things that were incomprehensible
I also saw government agencies that did
that so you know I mean at the DC
Circuit you got a lot of administrative
law decisions I felt like I needed an
acronym charge EPA and NLRB and and the
dreaded the worst was FERC no one wanted
FERC cases should I even ask ya Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission
anytime someone wants to build a
pipeline FERC is involved anytime
someone wants to do nuclear energy or
electric energy FERC is involved and
they're constantly being sued sued and
they're not the most exciting cases in
the world
right so to that point though how much
did you see are you talking about the
sausage being made how much did you see
it just sort of like a corroded system
like just a lot of nonsense that that
didn't need to be there you know just
like a lot of brush in the way well I
think the laws way too complex but I was
was astounded at the judges on the DC
Circuit these are incredibly smart
people who really care and I was
impressed by all of them just their
dedication to the work and trying to
find right answers and so many of how we
think about courts as politically based
on divided decisions between
conservatives and liberals but for most
of those cases we had at the DC Circuit
that it was not a political issue and so
it was an issue that basically all the
judges were trying to just find the
right answer
yeah after being around this after being
in prison and part of that system and
then you know working with judges and
now and now teaching and all that how
much you think politics sort of seeps
into all of this do you think people are
judges I'm talking about lawyers
everybody do you think public defenders
do you think people are able to remove
their own political biases no of course
not of course not
I I see politics plays a big role in
everything even the courts and I don't
think anyone would disagree with that
what I would say is that again there's a
large number of cases that don't involve
that that are pretty
straight forward and that is the bulk of
federal courts docket it's just we tend
to focus on the big case especially at
the Supreme Court the five before
decisions sure and we don't realize that
there are a whole lot of unanimous
decisions and a lot of collegiality on
the court except for in the big
political cases yeah so there are a
couple issues that are sort of your pet
issues now that are very personal to you
obviously so mandatory minimums you are
you are not a fan to say lawful just
describe what they are first but yeah so
mandatory minimums are aware Congress
sets a particular mandatory floor for
the judge has to impose that sentence
and I'll give you example of one of the
worst ones there is a statute that says
if you use a firearm during a crime of
violence or a drug trafficking crime you
get five years consecutive to whatever
else you get whether it's bank robbery
drug crime and then every second time
really its consecutive so this is
happening at the same time no matter
what so so if you get three years for
the robberies and that's five years for
the gun you're gonna do eight years yeah
the second time you know that seems not
consecutive I would have thought they're
sort of built on top of each other like
you know no you say okay yeah and then
you'd get a charged with a second use of
the firearm it's 25 years mm-hmm
had that played out for me and had I
gone to trial I would have had five bank
robberies and these five gun charges i
pled guilty to the five bank robberies
and one gun charge my sentence was
twelve years three months if I had gone
to trial and been convicted of the five
gun charges I would have received a
sentence of ninety two years and three
months the judge would have had to
impose it there's a very well known case
of Weldon Angelo's a man in Utah who had
a young family with selling marijuana to
support his young kids and made three
small sales of marijuana while having a
gun and he ends up getting sentenced to
55 years he's now been released I know
other people I've got a good friend
who's named Adam Clawson who did nine
robberies went to trial and the only
difference between his
case in my case is I had a good lawyer
he didn't I had a reasonable prosecutor
he didn't I pled guilty he exercised his
right to a jury trial and as a result he
got a sentence of 213 years in federal
prison Wow even though no one was
physically hurt in the robberies so it
makes no sense to me
yeah so for as misguided as obviously
you would argue these laws are the art
the counter-argument would be that this
is going to deter people I think that's
what the counter-argument is but as you
said before nobody understands this
stuff so have they done Studies on that
like oh yeah this is a literature all
says that the thing that deters people
is whether or not they're gonna get
caught not the length of the sentence no
one thinking about the punishment when
they're committing crimes and so you're
getting very little deterrent effect
yeah and so then the question is well
why do we impose mandatory minimums and
the government would say when we need
mandatory minimums to get people to
plead guilty well we have a problem in
the federal system with too many people
plead guilty ninety seven percent mm-hmm
and that shouldn't be our primary focus
and yeah I see wait why is that so high
ninety-seven percent because the
punishments are so high if if you are
offered three years and you might be in
a center have a triable case and you're
offered a plea deal of three years but
if you go to trial you're gonna get
twenty what would you do even if you're
innocent what would you do yeah you'd
probably take two three years because
the consequences are so severe so these
all of these people that got these
ridiculously high punishments at first
one I started seeing them I thought
maybe there is a connection to race or
socioeconomic class but really what I
see are people that exercise their
constitutional right to a jury trial
mm-hmm get thrown in prison for the rest
of their lives simply because they did
that and you know the jury trial right
is it's the only right that's both
contained in the body of the
Constitution and in the Bill of Rights
yeah I understand important thing yeah
so basically these laws the system is
sort of forcing you to not use your
constitutional right I mean that
really fascinating that's a term what
they call a trial penalty if you go to
trial you will get crushed because the
Department of Justice has 5000 federal
statutes many of them contain mandatory
minimum punishments let's think about
that five thousand things that you could
potentially do that would warrant
putting you in prison or jail I'd argue
that the United States does not value
your Liberty if there are five thousand
things that they think are so serious
that you could go to prison for yeah I
thought you're gonna say there's five
thousand things the United States
Congress could be in jail for well yeah
I mean I think most people break federal
law all the time and don't know it like
what for example people that omit
something material when they're selling
something on Craigslist or Ebay that's
wire fraud and I can tell you the last
three presidents United States committed
a federal felony all three of there's a
statute that says if you use or abuse
drugs any drug listen under the
controlled substance act and then
possess a firearm you're it's like
you're felon in possession of a firearm
hmm President Clinton what'd he say I
did I smoked that I didn't inhale
President Bush admitted to using drugs
and so did President Obama and all three
of them have possessed firearms since
then mm-hmm
they could have been convicted and
sentenced up to ten years in federal
prison so we have a Congress that has
passed 5,000 things and right these
really broad statutes and when they do
that what they pass is no longer the law
because what is the law is whatever your
local United States Assistant Attorney
decides to prosecute that's the law not
what Congress passes because Congress
has criminalized everything but really
decided nothing
[Music]
you
[Music]